I feel like tonight went pretty well for
you guys I mean what would you say I
mean we got our highest scores yet and
they see that we're working and we are
working and the fact that people keep
voting for us it's like it's just the
best blessing ever so I'm so happy
oh I feel amazing I'm so proud of
Shangela of this Tango it was the best
dance yet we got five nines
um and just overall is I think to me
personally has been one of my best
seasons you know and uh it's just so fun
to dance with Shangela and just the
whole vibe is like just different like
one thing we're gonna do is turn up okay
um I also have to ask Michael Buble how
do you think he did tonight how would
you grade him as a judge oh baby he's
getting a 10 for me it's Michael Buble
and you know I love Beyonce so I call
him Michael bubleonte okay
it was so much fun and you know what I
knew those judges including Michael were
looking for crispy legs and trust me
from right in here I brought them crispy
legs so did you really do the full dance
with those just tucked in yes I'm a drag
queen I'm no stranger to tucking things
in okay but also I have to say you know
I I'm from Texas I love chicken so
having it close to my heart was nothing
new for me
uh were you surprised that Tyra actually
ate the chicken baby I was so not only
was I surprised I was impressed because
you know like me being from Texas we
live for a person that knows how to go
in on a drumstick and my sister went in
tonight amazing
um you know and next week is Halloween
uh night obviously that's usually a
pretty big night for Dancing With the
Stars are you guys excited what can you
tease ooh tell them tell them something
Halloween baby well actually it's my
favorite holiday you know love dressing
up it's gonna be it's and it's the whole
night is super spooky and super creative
like every single we got team dance too
so every single couple and our team uh
we're gonna try to come up with
something fun you know and scary boo
I feel like if you don't have the other
show next week I mean come on I mean
come on I'm so excited for next week
because I'm a drag Entertainer custom
you know I love putting on costumes and
characters and dressing up but Halloween
is a special time of year that you get
to do something outside of who you
usually are so we're gonna bring you
something that you ain't never seen a
before